y
[Música]
europa se muestra harta de usar
mascarillas para combatir la pandemia en
algunos países del continente como
alemania francia y reino unido- se
celebraron protestas rechazando el uso
obligatorio del cubrebocas
al menos 15 muertos deja laura que tocó
tierra como huracán de categoría 4 en
eeuu y dejó a su paso ciudades inundadas
y sin electricidad en texas y luisiana a
donde ha llegado el presidente de donald
trump
el barco humanitario financiado por el
artista callejero banks y pide ayuda
tras rebasar su capacidad de migrantes a
bordo la guardia costera italiana acudió
al llamado y traslado a 49 personas la
mayoría mujeres y niños pero la
emergencia está lejos de terminar
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria las personas contrarias al
uso de cubrebocas obligatorios se
manifestaron en diversas ciudades de
europa en berlín se registró la
manifestación más multitudinaria contra
las medidas para frenar al coronavirus
la policía arrestó a 300 personas en
parís y londres también se registraron
concentraciones a pesar de los rebrotes
que se han presentado vamos a este
informe de álvaro del cordero
miles de personas se concentraron en
berlín contra las medidas impuestas por
el gobierno para controlar los rebrotes
que aseguran han terminado con su
libertad mantienen que todo es una farsa
orquestada que el gobierno aprovecha
para obtener más poder aunque fue de
carácter pacífico la manifestación no
cumplió ninguna de las normas sanitarias
exigidas por las autoridades que habían
dado luz verde a la protesta y la
policía de la capital alemana se vio
obligada a intervenir y disolver lo
exijo por mí mismo la vuelta de mis
derechos básicos no en algún momento
sino ahora mismo exijo que se vuelvan
mis derechos básicos exijo la libertad
de expresión como la teníamos antes
también la libertad en los medios y un
trabajo periodístico libre nada de
prensa mentirosa quiero que volvamos a
como estábamos éramos una democracia y
despertamos en una dictadura benedicto
en parís
el seguimiento fue mucho menor pero el
fin fue el mismo protestar contra el uso
obligatorio del tapabocas y denunciar la
posible vacunación obligatoria que ellos
consideran dañina la policía rodeó a los
asistentes rápidamente
muchos fueron multados con 135 euros por
no llevar mascarillas
estoy aquí por el uso de mascarillas no
creo que sea correcto que sea un decreto
obligatorio el uso de máscaras también
provoca miedo terror y tal vez obliga a
la gente a aceptar la imposición de
vacunar para deshacerse del tapabocas no
quiero que la vacunación sea obligatoria
en reino unido- cientos de personas
también se reunieron en el centro de
londres para protestar contra las
medidas del boris johnson todo ello
cuando europa enfrenta el segundo
rebrote de la enfermedad que ya está
causando estragos
en información latinoamericana de la
pandemia del cob y 19 este sábado brasil
el segundo país con más casos en el
mundo después de eeuu superó las 120 mil
muertes por el coronavirus el gigante
sudamericano registra 3 millones 846 mil
casos
nos vamos a eeuu donde manifestantes
vigilados por la guardia nacional
marchan en kenosha en rechazo al racismo
y la violencia policial y a favor de
jake blake un hombre afroestadounidense
a que en un oficial les disparó por la
espalda mientras tanto el presidente de
donald trump dijo que probablemente
visitará la ciudad blake que permanece
en un hospital se prepara para una
posible comparecencia virtual ante la
justicia por acusaciones de presunta
agresión contra su expareja vamos a este
informe de daniela hablando
que jake blake estaba armado y luchó con
fuerza contra la autoridad este es el
argumento con el que la policía de la
ciudad estadounidense de que no se
defiende las actuaciones del oficial que
el 23 de agosto disparó a la espalda del
ciudadano afroamericano luego de que al
parecer se resistiera a ser arrestado
el señor blake rodeó su vehículo abrió
la puerta del lado del conductor y se
inclinó hacia adelante mientras sostenía
su camisa el oficial su tensa skip
disparó su arma de servicio siete veces
contra su espalda durante la
investigación posterior al incidente el
señor blake admitió que tenía un
cuchillo en su poder los agentes de la
dirección de investigación criminal
recuperaron el cuchillo del lado del
conductor del vehículo y no se
encontraron armas adicionales chesqui y
otros agentes que estuvieron presentes
fueron puestos en licencia
administrativa mientras blake a afronta
su propio proceso judicial
acusado de haber agredido sexualmente a
su ex pareja y madre de sus tres hijos
de que permaneció esposado hasta el
viernes en la cama del hospital en donde
se recupera sus abogados no descartan
que la próxima semana acuda virtualmente
a una audiencia judicial y se declara
inocente aunque ya fue dejado en
libertad la noticia de que jake blake
que estaba esposado difundida al jueves
por sus familiares provocó una nueva ola
de protestas anti racismo en todo el
país que continuaron este sábado y trump
visitó las zonas afectadas por el
huracán laura el mandatario recorrió
texas y luisiana donde se reunió con los
trabajadores que atendieron la
emergencia mientras tanto comienza el
difícil proceso de reconstrucción de las
zonas devastadas por el huracán que tocó
tierra como categoría 4 aunque ella se
degradó a depresión tropical el impacto
del fenómeno fue menor al esperado
originalmente pero miles siguen sin
servicio eléctrico o de agua potable
veamos este informe de aurora bajo
luisiana comenzó un largo y difícil
camino hacia la recuperación tras el
paso del poderoso huracán la hora hay
ciudades inundadas y comunidades sin
servicios básicos como agua potable o
electricidad
los residentes de lakers regresaron para
ver lo que quedó de sus hogares acabo de
volver a la ciudad hoy solo para echar
un vistazo a las cosas y mi casa está en
muy mal estado pero seguiremos el paso a
la vez pieza por pieza vamos a volver a
contarlo todo revisando la comunidad la
hora tocó tierra con vientos de hasta
240 kilómetros por hora más fuertes
incluso que los del huracán katrina de
2005 es el 2020 que se puede hacer la
mayoría de las muertes fueron producto
de árboles que se estrellaron contra las
viviendas o por envenenamiento con
monóxido de carbono debido al mal uso de
generadores eléctricos sin embargo el
daño es menor de lo esperado no quiero
minimizar la en absoluto es una tormenta
terrible mucha gente ha perdido muchas
cosas pero estamos agradecidos
que no se haya inundado y no estamos
haciendo rescates de agua rescates de
agua rápida o cosas de esa naturaleza
se estima que 8.000 viviendas fueron
destruidas y más de 14.000 personas
buscaron refugio en la cruz roja y otros
organismos
miles de personas se manifestaron en la
capital de mauricio en rechazo a la
gestión gubernamental del desastre
ecológico que causó el derrame de
combustible del 25 de julio en el
sureste de la isla y que ha ocasionado
impactos negativos en la región el 26 de
agosto se hallaron en las playas de
mauricio a trece delfines sin vida y
agonizando una cifra que ha ido
aumentando desde entonces este viernes
se han encontrado más de 39 animales
marinos muertos
nos vamos a mali donde la primera
consulta enfocada a discutir el futuro
del país finalmente no se llevó a cabo
los miembros de la junta militar habían
planificado este sábado una reunión
inicial para la transición del poder
luego del golpe de estado del 18 de
agosto sin embargo la primera consulta
se pospuso a última hora un primer
fracaso para el movimiento 5 de junio
uno de los principales artífices de las
protestas contra el derrocado presidente
ibrahim boubacar keita
en otros temas el barco humanitario
financiado por el artista británico
banksy necesita ayuda inmediata después
de haber rescatado migrantes en el
mediterráneo
el barco salvó a más de 200 personas que
estaban atrapadas en una barcaza que se
estaba hundiendo lo que excede por mucho
su capacidad para transportar un máximo
de 120 personas y ahora navega al sur de
lampedusa con sobrepeso y pide ayuda la
guardia costera italiana envió una
patrulla de apoyo pero esto no es
suficiente
desde el pasado jueves ha rescatado a
más de 200 migrantes en el mediterráneo
central incluyendo mujeres y niños pero
ahora la embarcación humanitaria
financiada por banks y dio a conocer que
se encuentra al máximo de su capacidad y
necesita ayuda inmediata ya hay una
persona muerta en el barco los otros
tienen quemaduras de combustible han
estado en el mar durante días y ahora
los han dejado solos en una zona de
rescate de la unión europea numeral
louis michel no puede moverse ya no es
la maestra de su maniobra debido a la
cubierta abarrotada y una balsa
salvavidas explicada a su lado pero
sobre todo debido a que europa ignora no
hasta llamadas de emergencia para
asistencia inmediata el artista
callejero vivo más conocido del mundo
pero cuya identidad se desconoce abordar
regularmente la crisis de la migración
en sus obras en el mediterráneo la ruta
de emigración más mortífera para quienes
buscan llegar a europa
las embarcaciones improvisadas se han
multiplicado en 2020 este año más de 300
migrantes han muerto en el intento de
cruzar
llegamos al final de esta emisión les
agradecemos mucho su compañía siga con
más en france24 y cuídese cuídese mucho
del cobi 19
[Música]